une soixantaine de manifestations contre
la pma ce samedi à l'initiative de
plusieurs collectifs d'associations dont
la manif pour tous à paris vous le voyez
place vendôme a pas plus d'un millier de
personnes règle sanitaire oblige elles
ont protesté contre le projet de loi
bioéthique en particulier contre
l'ouverture à la pma pour toutes les
femmes des manifestants qui demandent le
retrait de ce projet de loi bioéthique
elle proteste contre la pma son père et
la gpa un texte qui a été voté le 1er
août en deuxième lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
projet de loi qui devrait être adoptée
définitivement dans les prochains mois
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter kirill kotick up place vendôme
à paris
les horaires et les consignes ont été
respectées à la lettre aujourd'hui pour
ce rassemblement sur la place vendôme
manifestation a débuté à 15 heures
tapantes et s'est terminée à 17 heures
pile pas plus de 1000 personnes
rassemblées ici sur la place vendôme aux
raisons du covin officiellement avec de
nombreuses prises de parole tout au long
de l'après midi des membres
d'associations anti ivg la manif pour
tous dont le président le vice-président
de cette manif pour tous albéric du
monde qui s'est exprimé au micro de rtl
france je crois que malgré un contexte
sanitaire exigeant malgré une vie
démocratique dégrade et les français ont
répondu présent à l'appel du collectif
marche aux enfants ils si place vendôme
est aussi dans 60 villes en france pour
dire non au gouvernement pour dire non
ce n'est pas le moment de faire passer
un tel texte
on est en pleine crise sanitaire une
pleine crise économique sociale et la
priorité des manuels macron c'est la pma
sans père sinon il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas dans ce gouvernement et nous
sommes là pour lui rappeler notre
position
notre détermination contre soit exclu on
est bien évidemment loin du 1 million et
demi de personnes rassemblées dans toute
la france il ya sept ans mais les
membres de cette manif pour tous
comptait bien montrer qu'ils étaient bel
et bien présents pour continuer leur
combat avec de nombreux drapeaux rouges
et verts qui ont été agités tout au long
de l'après-midi par les manifestants des
drapeaux sur lesquelles on pouvait lire
liberté égalité paternité une
manifestation qui s'est donc terminée
aux alentours de 17 heures avec 60
autres manifestations qui étaient
prévues un peu partout en france et pour
en parler de ces manifestations nous
sommes ce soir avec fatima benomar
fondatrice de l'association les
effrontés et lui devine de l'archère
président de la manif pour tous
bienvenu merci à toutes les deux d'être
sur ce plateau pour débattre de cette
question lui devine de la recherche je
me tourne d'abord vers vous il y a eu 60
une soixantaine de villes avec ces
manifestations
pourquoi aujourd'hui on l'a entendu il
ya un contexte de crise sanitaire
pourquoi prendre ces risques
alors qu' il vaut mieux rester chez soi
alors on a vu que malgré la crise
sanitaire et dans la plus grande
discrétion
emmanuel macron sans le dire dans aucune
de ces allocations publiques a voulu
faire avancer en catimini pendant l'été
ce projet de loi de bioéthique dit de
bioéthique
donc elle a passé la seconde lecture à
l'assemblée nationale dans des
conditions invraissemblables avec un
débat utile et sans vote solennel des
ministres qui ont été largement absents
et pendant ce temps là le gouvernement
ne cessez de dire la priorité des
priorités c'est l'emploi et le fait
qu'il avance avec ce projet de loi est
l'étape suivante la seconde lecture au
sénat le calendrier l'étape suivante
n'est pas encore fixée mais nous
voulions et nous devons impérativement
être présent dans la rue pour exprimer
le fait que ce projet de loi propose de
grands problèmes alors c'était 60
manifestations pour respecter bien sûr
la protection de la santé de tous ceux
qui voulaient défiler qu'il voulait
s'exprimer dans la rue
nous avons évité un grand rassemblement
national
trop nombreux en démultipliant les lieux
de rendez-vous 60 manifestations
c'est exceptionnel aucun parti aucun
groupement ou syndicats ne fait de
telles démonstrations de force
alors il y avait aussi des
contre-manifestations aujourd'hui fatima
benomar vous en étiez j'imagine pourquoi
ces contre-manifestation vous dites pour
couvrir les voix
ça sert à quoi non je ne vais pas fait
partie des manifestations pour ma part
parce que ça fait quand même huit ans
qu'on manifeste et qu'on débat sur cette
question sur la foi d'une promesse
d'ailleurs qui a été fait dès 2012 par
l'ancien candidat françois hollande
d'ouvrir la pma à toutes les femmes aux
couples de femmes aux femmes
célibataires et là ce qu'on veut c'est
très très vite le vote définitif
la promulgation et le fait de sécuriser
les familles et d'ailleurs je voyais les
manifestations parler au nom des
français pour le coup les sondages sont
toujours restés favorables au droit des
femmes de fonder des familles et des
familles homoparentales
c'est fou les mensonges aussi co
continue à entendre dans ces
manifestations par rapport à
l'affiliation au mont à l'enfant déjà en
général quand on a recours à une pma on
n'a pas besoin de mentir à un enfant est
en général d'ailleurs dans les couples
de même sexe vous imaginez bien que
l'enfant est bien assez tôt au courant
qu'il a était issue d'une pma
contrairement au couple deux hétéros en
fait qui ont recours à une pma qui
peuvent parfois se permettre de mentir à
leurs enfants et en fait nos opposants
ce n'est pas l'établissement de la
filiation par un parent qui n'est pas
biologique qui vais-je m
même à l'extrême droite marion
maréchal-le pen d'ailleurs qui a rajouté
maréchal dans son nom de famille est
complètement pour la reconnaissance et
la parfaitement reconnu que son père non
biologique s'est occupé d'elle l'a
reconnu et donc que c 'est c'est son
père donc la pérennité en france elle
est déclaratif quand un homme est en
couple avec une femme si elle accouche
il est reconnu par la loi et pas besoin
de faire un test et donc c'est le projet
familial qui prime dans le ciel
exactement la même chose je vous le
donne en mille pour les couples de
femmes
et ben quand elle
d'une famille quand elles s'occupent de
leurs enfants les ben elle devrait être
reconnu et ce n'est ni un mensonge qui
fait à leurs enfants c'est tout
simplement l'établissement d'un projet
familial et d'ailleurs on voit que ces
sujets n'ont pas nos opposants quand il
s'agit de couples de sexe opposé
on va pas refaire tout le débat on a
beaucoup beaucoup parler évidemment de
tout c'est tous ces détails du texte de
loi
c'est le moment en fait qui est
important aujourd'hui on est en pleine
crise sanitaire 56% des français c'est
un autre sondage publié hier pense que
le projet de loi aurait pu être
reportées vu le contexte il ya d'autres
priorités vous ne pensez pas un fatima
benomar toujours eu d'autres priorités
depuis 2012 c'est à dire que quand est
ce qu'on va reconnaître le droit de ces
personnes de fonder une famille et en
abstraction à tout ce qui peut se passer
ailleurs dans le monde il va toujours y
avoir malheureusement un des crises
économiques des crises politiques des du
terrorisme et cetera en fait ils vont
voir ces familles ne peuvent pas
attendre qu'on ait résolu tous les
problèmes de l'univers et tous ceux qui
vont se poser et la crise écologique et
que sèche pour qu'on s'occupe d'elle et
d'ailleurs ça a toujours été comme ça
par rapport à tous les droits
reproductifs notamment aux droits des
femmes si vous avez toujours à couper
ils vont va faire la révolution on va en
parler sous traiter le problème puis
après on s'occupera des bonnes femmes
c'est pas possible
à un moment il faut inscrire nos droits
dans l'agenda ne serait ce que par
rapport après la promesse de la pma sa
fille de huit ans qu'on attend et il y
aura toujours des conjonctures et il
faudra repousser jusqu'à quand elle les
devine de la recherche c'est un argument
que vous mettez en avant le coût
justement de la prise en charge puisque
ces pma devraient être remboursés par la
sécurité sociale
on le sait qui était mise à mal
aujourd'hui à cause du coc vide
donc c'est pour moi un argument
supplémentaire alors le sujet essentiel
de ce projet de loi les sujets il ya
beaucoup de succès dans ce projet de loi
il y à la pma dans un contexte qui
volontairement pris 20 enfants de pères
toute sa vie ça c'est fondamental
un père dans la vie de tout enfant c'est
très important et une mère mais mme
demers inscrits sur son acte de
naissance et c'est là que nous par
un mensonge un enfant n'a pas de maire
il peut avoir une mairie une belle-mère
mais une mer où deux femmes ne remplace
pas la paire c'est une injustice immense
la vraie vie il y a des enfants qui
n'ont pas de pair meetic
alors il ya les cercles les aléas de la
vie qui malheureusement font que des
enfants sont privés de leur père pour
toutes sortes de raisons là la
différence c'est qu'on veut
volontairement privé des enfants de
pères et on veux l'effacer il disparaît
même de son acte de naissance on
prétendrait qu'il a deux mamans ce qui
n'est pas vrai encore une fois il peut
avoir une mairie une belle-mère oui bien
sûr c'est pas le c'est pas la question
l'autre chose c'est que dans ce projet
de loi de bioéthique il faut savoir
qu'il y a aussi la volonté de créer des
embryons génétiquement modifiés des
embryons humains 2 me de créer aussi des
embryons chimères animal hommes il y a
la volonté de créer des gammes est
artificielle et de les fréquenter etc
etc et donc ce projet de loi pose des
questions humaines et éthiques
immense et pour en revenir à la pma qui
intéresse plus particulièrement madame
et madame je vous invite à regarder le
reste du projet de loi et ses
conséquences et à penser à l'avenir il y
a néanmoins un fait qui est que l'enfant
n'est pas un droit
un enfant vous parler de projet familial
projet parental
il n'y a pas de droit à fonder une
famille ça n'existe pas il n'y a pas de
droit à l'enfant
vous réclamez des droits des droits des
droits mais qu'est ce que vous faites de
ces enfants que l'eau volontairement
aubry dre de père est donc ce n'est pas
acceptable et d'ailleurs vous pariez des
sondages dans tous les sondages qui se
succèdent
quand on parle de l'enfant qui est le
premier concerné par la pma avant les
adultes et bien 85% des français
répondent que évidemment l'enfant né par
pma a le droit d'avoir un père et une
mère
comme tous les enfants et pour revenir
au calendrier actuel ce sont des sujets
fondamentaux des sujets avec des
conséquences anthropologique humaine
éthique immense le fait est que excusez
moi
le gouvernement a devant lui des
urgences absolues
ils n'arrêtent pas de
la priorité des priorités c'est l'emploi
c'est la crise et en fait ce qu il a
fait cet été il a passé en catimini et
en douce sur ce projet de loi pour le
faire avancer
et le gouvernement n'est pas à l'aise il
sait très bien que ça n'est pas vrai
quand on pose les questions précises sur
ce qu'implique ce projet de loi les
réponses sont tout à fait différentes
et de fait encore une fois aujourd'hui
malgré un contexte qui est inquiétant
pour tout le monde
malgré la difficulté d'organiser des
rassemblements
il y avait beaucoup de français partout
dans la rue aujourd'hui
et ce sont des français qui sont pas là
à dire mes droits mais droit mais droit
et nous on a fermé intérêts personnels
ils sont dans la rue pour défendre le
plus faible enfants pour défendre aussi
le respect de l'intégrité de l'être
humain
l'écologie on ne cesse d'en parler on a
dévasté la faune la flore la terre
l'environnement et on est en train avec
des apprentis sorciers qui veulent faire
des embryons transgéniques et des
embryons chimérique
on envisage aussi de dévaster de ne pas
respecter tout simplement la nature
humaine
ce projet de loi est éminemment grave et
dans un tel contexte aussi grave qu
aujourd'hui c'est bien particulier ça
n'est pas le moment il faut prendre du
recul
il faut prendre du temps il faut être
serein et peut-être aussi prendre en
compte
justement les questions écologiques et
cette crise sanitaire qui a montré toute
la vulnérabilité de l'homme qui a montré
aussi la difficulté pour la médecine
d'exercer sa tâche immense et complexe
et la médecine
elle n'est pas là pour mener d utiliser
des techniques médicales pour des femmes
qui sont faits compte je le rappelle est
elle n'est pas là non plus pour réaliser
nos désirs individuels
ce sont toutes ces questions que madame
vous refusé d'évoquer vous ne voulez pas
réfléchir aux conséquences
et ça fait des années que je débats et
je vois que jamais parlé fatima benamar
qui veut répondre ont été débattus vous
vouliez répondre fatima benomar oui
absolument 16 bon évidemment
diffamatoire ça fait des années qu'on
travaille dans le détail pour favori
cette loi qu'on est auditionné à
l'assemblée nationale pour répondre dans
les détails c'est extrêmement méprisant
et les violents de dire que les couples
de mer ne s'occupe pas au droit du droit
des enfants et de leur bien-être dans
toutes les les cas d'adoption et de
filiation on n'a jamais vu qu'ils
avaient un dédain de la part de ses
parents par rapport à leurs enfants on
ne voit pas et que les enfants qui sont
adoptés par des parents de même sexe
soient plus malheureux et c'est là aussi
c'est complètement encore une fois de la
stigmatisation des projets parentaux
bien sûr qu'elles s'occupent des droits
de leurs enfants maintenant ce qui est
important c'est de renforcer ses droits
c'est à dire de ne pas faire de la pma
effectivement un droit de riches il faut
est tout simplement le remboursement
afin de permettre ces projets par année
aux et je suis absolument par ailleurs
d'accord avec vous sur la question de
d'arrêter de maltraiter la nature et bat
typiquement nous souhaiterions que dans
cette loi entre elles on compte
d'ailleurs la question des intersexe
parce que ça ne semblait pas beaucoup
vous déranger mais aujourd'hui il ya des
opérations qui sont faites sur des bébés
et des traitements médicaux qui leur
sont imposées quand il ya des enfants
intersexe à l'encontre de toutes les
recommandations internationales qui est
des nombreuses interpellations de l'onu
mais là quand il s'agit de se conformer
au fond au fantasme pour faire bricoler
des enfants à l'image de ce que l'on
souhaite là il ya aucun problème
on peut donner le coup de pistolet à des
bébés on va faire des personnes et des
filles
contrairement à ce que la nature avait
prévu donc et nous sommes absolument pas
dans les mains du destin de ces enfants
ne souhaitant sécuriser leur leur
parcours et on n'a jamais vu qui est
statistiquement plus d'enfants qui une
fois grandi disent qu'ils sont
particulièrement leurs beaux endroits
ont été particulièrement bafouée et par
rapport à cette histoire de beau-père ou
de belle-mère là aussi c'est une
différenciation que vous faites
selon les familles par exemple quand un
père adoptif reconnaît un enfant vous ne
demandez pas ce qu'il soit reconnu comme
un beau père monsieur maréchal pour
prendre cet exemple un peu cocasse parce
qu'il s'agit de quelqu'un qui
manifestent avec la miche pour tous
n'est pas reconnu comme le beau père de
marion le
elle a repris son nom de famille et
c'est devenu son père parce qu'il l'a
reconnu parce qu'il s'est occupé d'elle
et parce qu'il ait eu l'établissement de
cette filiation illinois se réparer peu
de temps un mot lui devine de la rochère
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
vous savez très bien que dans le cas
d'un homme et une femme c'est une
filiation vraisemblable et vous parlez
des enfants orphelins orphelins parce
que la vie les a rendus orphelins ils
sont adoptés par des familles aimantes
oui parce qu'on essaie de réparer au
mieux leur situation et malgré cela vous
savez très bien que la plupart d'entre
eux cherchent à connaître leurs parents
qui sont des parents charnelle aussi sur
le psychique il les cherche benzema l'a
fait un temps de parole est gagé h 30
secondes par les cherche mais vous êtes
dans le déni des besoins de tout être
humain
l'amour c'est aussi de savoir renoncer à
ses propres désirs
par respect pour autrui et je ne je ne
dis pas du tout commenté ce n'est pas un
mensonge de cartes biologique dans
machete le pet les vivants la filiation
est ce aussi sur un projet parental
pourquoi vous demandez là j'allais aller
il ya une réalité il n'y a pas d'enfant
sans la nommer une femme et vous êtes
dans le déni de réel de la réalité même
pas besoin de connaître l'homme et la
femme dont ils sont nés cesse de passion
merci beaucoup c'est là c'est la fin de
ce débat il nous reste peu de temps
malheureusement ça mériterait davantage
qu'on s'y penche merci à toutes les deux
en tout cas d'être en direct et d'avoir
des bâtis en direct ce soir sur rtl
france et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi qui ai des camps
dit elvia pas d'alternative au sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
[Musique]